foreign
[Silence]
continuing our
weekly journey through
zed ilma's authored by the great imam
and sheikh of islam
even jose these
gatherings these gelasets where we sit
and we discuss
that which is most positive and that
which is of most
consequence in this life and the
hereafter
we discuss the best of mankind
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
we discuss how it is he went about
on his journey to allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
and that is really what this life is
this life is a journey
to allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
and eventually
every one of us will meet him
every one of us will speak to allah
to our maker
as the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
[Silence]
be
and i'd to share this narration
because it's important for us that
every time we sit down to discuss this
topic
or any topic of significance
we have to have some kind of
encouragement in our lives
to give us that push to do the right
thing
it's easy to fall asleep as a matter of
fact
everyone is sleeping except for those
whom allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
awakens and
as the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
said
the example the analogy of those who
remember allah
and those who are unaware
and in a spiritual slumber
are the living and the dead
that's the difference between them
in this narration the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam tells us something very
chilling
he says in the narration of adi even had
him
just collected by a muslim
he said there is not one of you
except that his lord is going to speak
to him
directly without any
intermediary or translator between them
yani there is not one of us i you every
single person
is going to stand in the most vulnerable
position
possible you know
it's mentioned in polls and in
statistically
that the thing people fear most
out of anything and it's actually
mentioned that people
fear it more than death itself
is public speaking to speak in front of
people
why is that because
when a person is up in front of people
they are quiet they are all focused on
him
and he is speaking he feels that he is
being
judged and there is one thing that
scares
every one of us as human beings and that
is the idea
of being judged it terrifies us to the
core
that's being judged by people
human beings who have no right to judge
us i mean every one of us has no right
to judge the other
every single one of us has enough
skeletons in his own closet
that gives him no high ground to look
down on his fellow
muslim brother or his fellow person or
human
or to judge anyone else or to point the
finger of content
contempt not one of us
this is why allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
says
judgment belongs and is the sole right
of allah alone
who has that high ground to judge
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said
s
suffices an individual in evil
is for him to merely belittle his fellow
muslim brother
this is why for instance things like
spying is a major sin in islam
for a person to spy on another muslim in
any way
even to just listen into his
conversation
without those people without the people
in that conversation to be
okay with that is a major sin in islam
why is that because none of us
has the higher ground to spy on the
other person
every one of us has skeletons
allah alone on his throne knows how many
they
are and how hideous in his closet
let alone for me to be going around
looking for other people's
mistakes and spying on them
and so the most
terrifying thing to the human being and
that is to be
judged there is not one
of us except that he is going to be
judged in that way
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
said
there is not one of you except that
allah is going to
speak to him directly without any
intermediary or translator between them
that is truly terrifying
you're going to stand in front of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
the one who knows the secret and
even what is more hidden and deep than
the secrets
so allah subhanahu wa ta'ala you are
going to stand
before him the one who is worthy of all
worship
the purest the most beautiful the jabbar
the greatest and you're going to be
judged and i am going to be
judged in that vulnerable position
when you are in that position you are
going to see
how it puts into perspective
when we are in that position just how
insignificant
and small we really are immediately
that circumstance of standing in front
of allah
immediately puts you into proof puts
your position into perspective
i'm nobody i'm really nothing
all of these years and time i thought i
was this and that
and i did this and i did nothing i'm
zero
i am a grain of dust
all right and so the prophet sallallahu
alaihi was
says and when that person
stands in front of allah and allah
speaks to him
what's meant by speaking to him is
speaking to him
about his or her particular life legacy
in other narrations allah will ask him
did you do this
did you not do this what about this
did you not fail to do this why did you
do this
why did you do that this is what's ahead
of every one of us
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
under these circumstances a person will
look
to his right now of course right here to
look to your right
that is
basically a reference it is an
it is a metaphor for your good deeds
because the
the angel that writes the good deeds is
on the right
and the angel that writes the bad deeds
and the sins is on the left
and so your right is your good deeds and
your left is your bad
deeds in this parable he says
he will look to his right and see
only what he has put forth meaning of
good deeds
then he will look to his left and see
only what he has put
forth meaning of his bad deeds
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
said
and then he will look back forward and
the only thing he will be
able to see is the fire licking
at his face what does that mean
meaning that under those circumstances
all of the nonsense aside all of the
whispers aside all of the
fakery and the fakeness of this world
aside
pure objective truth
when you are in that position and you
really look at your good deeds
and then you really look at your bad
deeds and you compare them
you will come to the conclusion that the
hellfire is
most certainly your demise
right and the reason for this
is that when we compare the good that we
do to the bad that we do
i mean we are we are fundamentally
making mistakes
and we have a few good deeds sprinkled
in there somewhere
and the good deeds that we do muster up
they are deficient
and they are lacking and incomplete and
half done
and half-heartedly done etcetera you
we all know what we're speaking about
here
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said and then when he looks back forward
he can see nothing but the fire meaning
his mind will just go blank and he will
think
oh my goodness i i have nothing to show
i have wasted my opportunity
and obviously i
i have no chance
the prophet sallallahu alaihi was said
he said so protect yourselves from the
fire
even if all you can muster up
is half of a date to give in charity
i am so poor that all i have is one date
split it in half eat a half and give the
other in charity just
just do something to protect yourself
from the fire
he said
he said and if you can't even muster up
a half of a date
a half of a date in charity to protect
yourself
then at least a kind word
to say to someone say something nice to
someone
say something positive command good
forbid evil encourage someone who's
going through a hard time
right relieve stress from someone
just tell somebody something that will
at least
make them feel better or make them feel
remorse and step onto the path
a statement of encouragement anything
just say something good something pure
not for any reason but for the sake of
saving yourself from the fire
this is this this epitomizes this
narration is a very
a very intense narration
this epitomizes the state of the human
being this is what we're all going
through
there is not one of us who is innocent
i'm not innocent and you're not innocent
we're all guilty and it is all about
attaining and achieving allah's mercy
we will not enter paradise because of
our greatness or our achievements
we will enter paradise because
allah found us worthy of his mercy
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was
foreign
he said try strive to do the right thing
strive to do good deeds and try to do
those good deeds
as best as you can but keep in mind
that not one of you will enter paradise
solely because of his own earnings
of good deeds
not one of us no matter how hard i try
i will still not make myself worthy
for paradise without allah's mercy
they asked the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam this question the companions
they said rasulullah
they said not even you ka'ale
he said not even i
will enter paradise solely by my own
earnings
and my own deeds i will only be admitted
into paradise
when allah subhanahu wa and after allah
engulfs me and envelops me in his mercy
and in his pardon
these are lessons of humility that we
have to understand
and why why do i mention this now how
does
this tie into what we're speaking about
from
well it ties in to the fact that
in the day and age that we live in media
has it's a brain parasite
it has completely taken hold of our
minds
and so people that are adults
40 50 60 year old people
right because of the
enormous amount of information that is
constantly flooding our senses
our eyes our ears our right
from our phones and our tv and
everything and everything is a big
big glamorous neon
sign right of entertainment and a hive
of distraction
everywhere right even when a person
goes to the bathroom and sits down on on
you know to relieve himself he's still
got the glittering
neon sign in his eyes he's got his phone
there and
radio and we've just got it everywhere
where our senses are being overflow
over overtaken they're being over
over stimulated by everything
right and so now
our attention span as human beings
has gone down as human beings we're not
good
at doing many things all at once this is
not what the human brain
was designed for this whole idea of
multitasking and having 25 things that
i'm doing at the same time
no the way that allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has designed the human brain
what it is good at is doing one thing at
a time
and doing it very good with great
attention to detail
i can only focus on my vision on one
thing at a time
i can only listen to one thing at a time
allah
has not given any one man two hearts
in his in his chest
and so because of this
our attention span has suffered
and so the recent recent polls have
shown that the
average attention span of a college
student
the average attention span of a college
is 10 seconds
10 seconds and that's why
advertisements now have been geared
towards 10 seconds
they got to draw you in in that first 10
seconds
so people are essentially just we
you know as humanity we've we've got
essentially the
the attention span of a gold of a
goldfish
right 10 mi 10 seconds
is the most a person can focus before
their mind starts to wander off onto
other things
because we're drug addicts we're
constantly looking for that stimulus
and so we see movies and and videos of
all this thing happening in this quick
cut
and you know 25 different images in in
in half a second and what this does is
it's caused our minds to
depend on that so then when we come to
read a book ze del maad when we
come to sit
in a lecture the lecture you're
listening to
now it's streaming
what is it there's no quick cuts there's
no graphics
there's no sound track there's no music
there's nothing to stimulate you on that
superficial level it's just
the the person delivering the lecture
the person of
knowledge the book and then we have to
speak about a subject
and a lot of the subjects or many of
them are abstract
issues and you have to pay attention you
can't be distracted
right and so
people will look at this and they will
start to
wander oh gosh it's so boring i'll
listen to five minutes five minutes and
that's too much
i can't hear the whole thing it's so
boring you start to fall asleep
right but this is where
paradise is these kinds of gatherings
if you want to find paradise on earth
this is paradise on earth right
and this is why because people become so
disinterested quickly
we see so-called imams so-called
scholars or leaders or what have you
they're more akin to an entertainer than
they are to an educator
right so they have to give these big
fancy hutbas and
and use all this fancy stuff and
make p as if they're speaking to
children and
there is an element where a person does
need to keep the
audience's the audience's attention
don't get me wrong and there's a place
for that and eloquence is
something that is praiseworthy but at
the same time
i don't need to come up here and tap
dance right to keep people's
attention it cheapens the conversation
it makes the subject that we're talking
about
cheap and this is one of the signs of
the hour that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam spoke about
he said and this narration is collected
by
imam al-bukhari in his book
[Silence]
strive and hasten to do good deeds
before
six things come to be in this world and
meaning signs of the hour and the sixth
thing he mentioned was
a people near the end of time that will
take the quran
as a musical a sheet of music
people will take a man and they will
place him
as their leader in prayer or leader
in
salah what have you not because he is
the most knowledgeable
not because he is the most understanding
or pious
the only reason he will have that
position is so that he can sing to them
and entertain them because now even the
quran isn't entertaining unless
we have we have some
you know some someone to sing to us
and so the point is is that
it's hard to focus on these things this
is a very traditional way of of speaking
you sit you listen to the scholar speak
or you listen to the
speak and you take in the information
and you have your own responsibility and
the information is not just like
some fun fact or some article that has
no bearing on your life
that's more akin to entertainment than
it is to study or knowledge
it's something that demands action when
i s when we
discuss things of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam of his
legacy this demands action
meaning that before this class
and after i can't be the same person
anymore i have now grown i have learned
something new
and now more is expected of me and this
is why a lot of people
run from this and they cover their ears
and they hide their heads
it's uncomfortable but it's necessary
nobody said it would be fun or
comfortable
but it is worth it that's the promise
that allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala gives us
in the quran
and so these are the gatherings of
paradise and so
when we hear this information
you know for you to pay attention for
40 45 minutes 50 minutes
to listen to the sun of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam this is how
scholarship works this is what you have
to do in order to learn
and so you have to train yourself and
build that muscle in your mind and in
your heart
to be able to put everything else out of
your mind
and focus on this thing because
this could be this sunnah that you're
about to learn or this hadith you're
about to learn or
could be the thing the one thing that
tips your scales
in your favor on the day of resurrection
could be
the one thing that enters you into
paradise and it's free
you don't have to pay money you don't
have to pay anything
right it's free the most precious
knowledge in this world
is free all you have to do is
be present for it your mind your
heart
you have to make time for it that's all
that is demanded
the person that is speaking the scholar
the person that is
disseminating the knowledge they get
nothing out of it
from this world that is with allah
subhanahu based on
his or her respective intention
today tonight we are going to continue
speaking about
an issue of jumuah and that is the
day of friday
the virtue of the day of friday
is speaking to us about the virtues of
the day of friday he says
foreign
[Silence]
he mentions here a narration which was
collected by
imam tiramida in his
very well-known book as sunan also
referred to as al-jammer
and tirmidhi graded it authentic on the
authority of abi hurairah who narrates
that the messenger of allah
said that which translates to
the best day the most virtuous day
upon which the sun has risen is the day
of jumu' the day of friday meaning of
the days of the week
on this day the day of jummah adam
was created
our forefather and on this day he was as
well
admitted into paradise right
and on this day he was as well
taken out of paradise
he says and the hour
the day of resurrection the day of
judgment the end of the world the
armageddon
will not be except on a day of jummah
so let's unpack this very quickly
what does this mean that it is the most
virtuous of days and then the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam mentions
virtues but some of them don't seem so
virtuous
so he says the best day of the week is
jummah
on that day adam was created okay that's
a positive and that's obviously
shows that's one of the many things that
expresses the
honor of the human being
and the high status that the human being
has with allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that allah chose to create adam create
the human being
on the best of the days of the week he
says
and on that day he was admitted into
paradise
not on the same day he was created
necessarily
because there was a time when
adam alaihissalam was shaped and
fashioned and as allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala referred to him as
meaning that he was shaped
okay and he was
hollow inside so he was set to dry when
we look at the quran
we see that there are stages in the
creation of the human being
we have a turab that the human being was
created from
dust or dirt then we have a theme
that the human being was created from
meaning that he was created from mud
that was
adhesive and sticky lazib meaning
elsa believed that he was
very soft and that that clay
would stick to your hands if you were to
handle it and then we have
hama immaze
means that he was shaped
he was given all of his features and his
shape
and he was set to dry and he was
meaning
if you were to knock on it it would
be hollow inside this is called hana
masnoon
so adam was created and shaped in this
way
on a friday right
and adam alaihissalam was created
on a friday but he was also admitted
into paradise on a friday there was
[Arabic recitation]
long
until allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and so when allah wa'ta'ala
put the soul into adam alaihissalam
it started from the head down to his
legs
it's a very well known narration this is
when
adam alaihissalam became a complete
human being
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala then admitted
him into paradise
and the day that he was entered into
paradise was the day of jumuah
he says now another
merit of the day of jumu'
is that on the day of jumu' adam
alaihissalam
was adam alaihis salaam was taken
out of paradise what does that mean
well when he committed the sin that he
committed
and allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala forgave
him for it
the consequences of that sin was that he
was
sent down to the earth with his
spouse eve in english
in arabic and that that was on the day
of
jumu' now how is that a merit of
jummah for him that was a
that was a that was a negative
consequence of a sin
well it was a great day because it
marked the beginning of the human race
on earth
it marked the beginning of when this
very
unique and special worship of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
was going to now not only be in the
heavens
but it was now going to descend and be
on the earth
so it was a great day in that sense he
says
and the day of resurrection the hour the
appointed time
of judgment will not be except on a
friday meaning this is the day when
allah
will end this earth and commence the
hereafter and that is a great merit for
the day of resurrection as well
he says
[Silence]
foreign
he mentions another narration which was
collected by
aliman malik in his book
and it was also graded authentic by a
tirmidhi
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said regarding the day of
jumu' the day of friday that it
is the best and most virtuous day of the
week
upon which the sun has risen
on that day of jumu' on on jumu'
adam was created and on that day he was
also he also descended which means that
he descended from the heavens from
paradise
onto the earth and began his life here
on earth with his wife
and also on the day of jumu' allah
forgave
adam right
now
so in the quran
teaches us that adam was taught
how to repent and taught about
repentance and taught exactly what to
say in order to seek allah's forgiveness
and that allah forgave him that this has
well happened on the day of jumu'
why is this information important to us
it's important to us because it lets us
know that on the day of jumu'
it is a special day of forgiveness as
well
that if a person were to seek allah's
forgiveness on the day of
on the day of jumu' that it is
more likely that this repentance will be
accepted as well on that day
he met and on that day adam alaihissalam
passed away so he died on a day of
jummah
and there are narrations in which the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam mentions that
one of the signs of
one of the signs that a person
has a good death and insha allah has a
good
future in the hereafter with allah
is that he or she dies on the day or
night of jumu'an
he says
and on the day of jumu' the hour will
be established
as well
he says
and on the day of jumu' there is a
time
this is all in the same narration
allah
and there is a time on the day of
jumu'
in which no muslim
will happen to be in prayer during that
time
asking allah for anything
except that allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
will give it to him this is called st
meaning that there is a time during the
day of jumu'
right and we're not sure exactly what
this time is or when this hour is but
there are narrations that indicate when
it is and we will discuss this next week
insha allah
this is called
this is a time when allah is most likely
to
accept thee or accept thee
request of any servant who
is asking him something during this time
so this from the days of the week
this one window
of opportunity in which allah is most
likely to
give someone what they ask for
it is on the day of jumu' when on the
day of jumu'
most narrations do not specify
most narrations do not specify very
very similar to
other times when a
great reward is found so for example
the night of
is a night in ramadan that has
great virtue and great and holds great
virtue and that is a night when allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
will accept a person's prayer and what a
person asks for he will be given on that
night
right and when we look to see
when is that night it's not really been
specified
exactly we're given indicators
we're given signs of that night it'd be
very still out there's not a lot of
wind you will not hear many
animals it'd be very calm night and
tranquil night
there are different things that the
prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam has mentioned
with regards to indicators
of what day or what night
the night of al-qaeda are
however it's not identified
explicitly with any particular night
why is that so that we strive through
the whole 10 days
because if we're told which day that is
then us we'll
put all our eggs in that basket and then
the rest of the
10 days we will become lackadaisical
and overtaken by laziness and that
defeats the purpose that
that that completely contradicts the
spirit
of leila whether it's leading up to it
or
coming down from it likewise it's jummah
when we see
things this very virtuous it's a
particular
particularly virtuous time or virtuous
day or virtuous
we're not always told when it is we're
giving indicators but
to kind of narrow it down but we're not
always told and the reason for that is
because most people would specify that
time
for fervent worship and leave off all
other time
whereas we are given a general
time so that we can
strive throughout that whole time and
maximize
our opportunity and maximize the
benefits of that day
we will conclude with that for this
evening inshaallah
next week we will continue on this
same
in this same vein
with regards to jumuah
after which we will discuss
the
the holidays
then we will also speak about el cusof
well josef
which is a specific prayer that is made
for eclipse
and we will also discuss solatul este
which is a prayer that is requesting
rainfall then we will get into
some of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's traditions
in travel how he would travel what he
would say the adria the etiquettes of
travel etc
and inshallah
we will continue on into there this will
segway us
after a few weeks into the beginning
of the prophet salallahu
and thank you very much